i think we got to talk about this
conspiracy this mcafee death
yeah yeah yeah kind of wild so
um i did some light research on him but
i probably don't know what you know so
bust it down bust it down because i just
know who he was
okay so he his big thing was he started
mcafee antivirus software which was the
first antivirus software
yep and then he later on really started
to hate like once he
kind of sold his share or whatever he
started to hate what it became publicly
was like you'll [ __ ] this company
then he left that company tried to start
a bunch of others that didn't work
he was the head of a tech startup for a
little while i think or like a tech
investment firm something like that
and then he started bitcoin mining and
saying bitcoin was the future made all
these outlandish claims it's going to
hit on 100 000
in 2019 million dollars in 2022. it
wouldn't happen then he just admits like
yeah and i was just doing that for
publicity to like try to drive the price
up
he's involved in murder cases
investigations yeah he was caught with
some sort of belize
he never paid taxes he believed
everybody should be tax free he ran for
president
of the libertarian party in 2016 and he
was openly like i don't pay taxes and
then fled the country because he doesn't
pay taxes he's just been a wild
[ __ ]
[ __ ] just been the wildest and
also just kind of wrapped up like
tangentially in conspiracy theories
throughout his life so many and so like
he would tweet something be like oh this
thing is the vaccine is bad for you
don't take it
yeah you say that kobe's a hoax kinda
and you would like
he was just wrapped up in a ton of
different conspiracies over time and
made a ton of different enemies
right like he had beef with the belizean
cartel the belizean government itself
was after him because they thought they
had killed his
he killed his neighbor right so and all
the people he would just talk [ __ ] about
generally i was speaking to a guy who
did uh not a documentary
on him but like an interview right yeah
he'd interviewed him like a while he
went to
his uh house in like nashville tennessee
and he was kind of like a
kook in the in in that way like he was
just always thinking people around to
get him
uh alex jones said that he was a spook
which means he was a spy
so he was working for somebody but he
was kind of like a missionary
missionary spot what is mercenary
mercenary spy so like different uh
countries or different
guns for higher economies guns for hire
but with spy yeah and uh the rumor was
that he had some like back channel
a way to get into um different
corporations uh
uh i guess like files through his
antivirus software
so like he left open some things where
he could like go through their files and
he had a lot of dirt on people
and the rumor was that there was going
to be this dead man switch that goes off
if he dies now
dead man switch has two very different
terms the guy i was speaking to
uh i said the term dead man switch he
goes yeah
that's not what you're saying for us
because he was in iraq for a while he
was like for us that's the guy who is
the suicide bomber
who's holding the switch and if you
shoot him and kill him
the switch goes off right so he's
holding down a dead man switch
he is the dead man right so you can't
kill him because the second you do
everybody exactly right but the dead
smith switch another term is also used
as
if you die all the documents that you've
accumulated
all this dirt you have on all these
other people it gets released means kind
of the same thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah but the literal term dead
man switch yeah
um effectively yes everybody else gets
[ __ ] over by killing him and that's
what keeps him alive yeah
uh and um so what's interesting is he
was kind of
leaning into conspiracy almost about his
own death like he got a tattoo that said
whacked
uh he said i'm not going to suicide
myself
so if i do die yeah it's somebody else
right i'm getting uh he had one tweet or
something about like
i'm hearing from the state department or
the deep state or the people that
control
the u.s that they want me out of here
blah blah blah
what i'm also hearing about this guy is
he's an absolute egomaniac he loves
attention
and if you were an egomaniac love
attention and we're going to kill
yourself because you were going to be
extradited to the u.s where you were
going to be put in jail for the rest of
your life
maybe you kill yourself in the most fun
way possible right
right like maybe you just take yourself
out because how much dirt does he really
have on people and how important is he
really in this game
apparently he had a bunch of like crypto
wallets that were worth like hundreds of
millions of dollars so maybe people
wanted that money
but outside of that you're not a real
player you're not an epstein
right you're not a maxwell right like
you're a guy who was
kind of included in these things but
like if you got beef with belize you
ain't got real beef yeah
you know no disrespect to belize but i
don't even know if they got an army
right
you know what i'm saying like there's
there's levels of beef and conspiracy
that got way bigger than the belizean
cause but i don't understand if he's a
spy why would he draw so much attention
to himself
sometimes i get confused there's a
disconnect for me well so like for
example like uh galen's
uh father yeah was a spy for mossad
allegedly okay and he was one of the
most public figures in history
he literally had a he had a media
company that was massive
so just because you're spy doesn't mean
you're undercover right sometimes the
fact that you're so famous gives you
access to these rooms
yeah and it gives you like alibi and
like oh i was just here because i was
doing a promotion
yeah so uh a guy that was like a family
friend of mi of my parents a guy named
mo berg
was the guy who like took the pictures
of what i think tokyo looked like or
something
that passed that information back to
america
and he did that when he was uh with
american baseball players while they
were playing
baseball against japan they made a movie
about them right i think they did
yeah yeah and uh he was kind of weird
kind of like
whatever anyway uh yeah information i
cannot share
he might have been he was no longer
allowed in my uh
family's home okay it's a little weird
yeah but uh
but point being like sometimes you take
those figures right like i'd be
surprised if they didn't do it with uh
people in sports
yeah like you know like some coaches are
gonna hey you're gonna be a coach for
the dallas mavericks while they go
to this game in the middle east
you know and we would love you to coach
for the team
and that's all yeah and definitely don't
scope out any of these other things
right you're a coach yeah like i
wouldn't be surprised if the olympics
people do the same thing
like if the olympics are in the united
states
you don't think that they're sneaking
spies why would you want the olympics in
your country then i guess money but like
you're just opening up to everybody i'm
a trainer for
uh whoever olympia shakira richardson or
whatever her name is
uh it's uh i'm just her i just helped
her stretch yeah i'm her masseuse yeah
and it's not like not every single
person is getting vetted and how good it
goes over there
that's not gonna stop spying you know i
mean like yeah these pies can get over
there yeah they're never business
like yeah yeah um if anything they're
probably gonna have more eyeballs on
them now because
they're like exchange their information
anyway back to this mcafee [ __ ]
so um i think i know this is crazy to
say
but i think it's just coincidence dude
and i think that we love the drama we
need the story it's kardashians like
i think there's a lot of interesting
things that are going on about this guy
and he like fits the build of all this
stuff
but i don't really think that he was
whacked i think he killed himself
and i think we love the idea of uh these
like famous successful people
that are being taken out by the deep
state because they have all this
information
i don't think the deep state gives a
[ __ ] that we know we knew about
epstein they still killed that
[ __ ] i think the deep state is
out there going
they don't care they don't care about
ufos they care about nothing
elaine's still locked up they probably
let that [ __ ] walk the lane probably on
the upper east side right now going to
saks fifth avenue buying hats
nobody gives a [ __ ] we are the not give
a [ __ ] people we just like to pretend
like we do
but then if they kill epstein to keep
information from getting out that's what
why they would kill mcafee theoretically
is to keep [ __ ] from getting out
we we can kill him and nobody's gonna
care if we kill him yeah but we can't
have that information
but i guess it's like confirm things
from getting out but like we've had so
many things that are almost confirmed
it's like
how many women accuse bill clinton or
rape and [ __ ] like that like
what do we really need bill to go i did
it yeah you know what i'm saying like
like how many
accusations do we need right right for
like do we think epstein's innocent no
we know
he did some foul [ __ ] right do we think
elaine's innocent no we know he's doing
fashion
do we know that all these other
[ __ ] were like buddy buddy with
them and going on vacations with them
yes
like what do we need to believe that
prince andrew was [ __ ] little girls
on that island
we got the girl that said it we got a
picture of both of them in the crib
it's true like how much more proof do we
need yeah and i think on some level we
care about the proof we just like the
entertainment
so he's our new form of entertainment oh
the sap scene [ __ ] is done
all right who else is new are you the
new thing to distract us are you our new
soap opera
yeah no that makes sense just like we
said with brittany we just want the
entertainment we just want to watch the
spectacle
the facts who cares that's not what's
important what's important is the fun
part the fun part is the speculating
it's our virtue signaling like
because we love to uh take down the
government oh the government's so [ __ ]
up the government's so corrupt we talk
all this [ __ ]
and we do it even on our podcast oh
they're so [ __ ] up and they're doing
this
and it's like what
you know it's like it's no different
than like i don't know why this relates
kind of but like
there's that that's a different subject
so we'll get to it later but
all i'm saying is it's a lot of [ __ ]
there's a lot of [ __ ] people
carrying like a lot of people oh we need
to get to the bottom of this mcafee
thing do we
or is that your newest netflix drama to
your argument earlier mcafee is more
real than
all of us because he was like i don't
believe in taxes i'm not paying them
i'm publicly not paying them government
do what you want life i'm about
it leaned into crypto yep that's
probably why he killed himself the
crypto market
yeah that's probably good that's really
someone told him that bitcoin went to 30
000. he said
sayonara yeah this podcast he was like
oh i'll buy it
yeah that's what you did you want the
delta variant to get out everywhere so
you killed the virus killer
damn hey hey hey i gotta do what i gotta
do for what
hey bro this is too much look my ticket
sales aren't good so nobody can do
comments
how about that how about that
[ __ ] kansas city
the jazz city hates on the city
that's the city's fault there's gonna be
a lot of covert over there's all i'm
saying yeah
delta coming through only [ __ ]
airline with direct flights did you
notice
uh uh what's uh what the mark what do
you think man you are are you a resident
conspiracy theorist i don't know it's
i mean when you said it was coincidence
i don't think it's coincidence okay go
so
i think that either he killed himself
knowing like yeah this is gonna be the
biggest thing like
he's all has all these cases against him
he's going to extradite to the u.s
people are like oh why would he kill
himself over just tax evasion or
whatever it's like first off tax evasion
you get
the book thrown at you if you steal
money from the government like they can
[ __ ] you over especially if you're a
public figure
that's made a whole movement out of this
and they're like yo you're telling all
these people to not pay their taxes you
got to send a message
like we will put you out forever derek
joven times five
yeah life think about this that director
[ __ ]
raped a girl and just eating baguettes
in
france now right i don't know there's
actually polanski polanski
we don't have extradition yeah they
don't have extradition like we can't
just yank [ __ ] out of france
right that being said if we wanted them
we could get we go full belarus we could
get him
we could go over there and we could get
him we could go dark knight rises
you know i mean send batman over there
snatch him like they did that chinese
dude remember a dark knight rising
belarus did the critic that uh
anti-government guy
belarus yeah or saudi arabia did it
belarus
took yeah so the dictator of belarus i
read his name is like it's not
it's not lomashenko but it's uh no he's
a boxer yeah
there's something really cool that's
pound for bomb boxing he's the best
pound-for-pound dictator in the world
yeah he really is he's a champion that's
fire
uh but basically he's gotta be kim
jong-un there was a guy
oh lukashenko okay so basically he
is pissed off at this critic that is
like talking all this mad [ __ ]
and the critic is flying from one
country to another country never going
to belarus flying directly over
belarus so literally lukashenko's
[ __ ]
cronies and like his government sends a
fighter jet
up to the ryanair commercial airline
holy [ __ ]
and goes yo you got to ground the plane
and they go why we're going from country
a to country b and they go
nah but you're in our airspace and
there's an issue with the plane and
there's an issue with you flying over
our airspace so you gotta land
and so the plane comes down they bring
authorities onto the plane
rip this [ __ ] off he's in prison
in belarus
even though he never went to the country
wow they just snatched him out of the
skyline
i look at that spiderman i love that
kind of fun i love that [ __ ] that's fire
i mean like it breaks every laws breaks
every level
they don't break the laws in belarus
like you don't say you just got exist by
you in our airspace knock knock
right like you only gotta abide by your
laws
he decided to fly over belarus we gotcha
[ __ ] that's what you get for flying
ryanair [ __ ] with you
exactly you want to take the fastest way
you've got to go around belarus i'm
never flying over belarus again by the
way
i want to see his yelp review on the
[ __ ] airlines like this airline sucks
super trash food was awful terrible
turbulence
i got murdered i mean that's crazy yeah
but
he's about that life and when you're a
dictator you get to dictate what the
policy is
mm-hmm i bet you ryanair don't do that
no more
i bet you but ryanair is going the long
way found some new routes yup
i mean it's just air up there i bet you
ryan they're still flying the same rocks
yeah they might broke [ __ ]
actually the spirit of europe yeah but
continue
but yeah so that just i forgot what we
got there is some of the magazine thing
yeah yeah i i agree with you what i
meant cons uh when i met um
did i think it was just what was
coincidence i think he means he just
wasn't murdered
yeah yeah yeah i'd have to see how he
committed suicide or committed
that's the other thing that they're i
think it was hanging but they're like we
have to know for sure we have to need to
do an autopsy they're like asking for
more time and it's like
what do you mean if he just hung himself
yeah he's dead you could tell us right
yeah what do you mean there's no pulse
he's dead meaning like you know you did
it from hanging
but i think they still need confirmation
from the autopsy oh yeah i mean but like
you could
poison someone and then hang them
afterwards i guess there's other things
yeah
so his wife is asking for she's asking
for independent autopsy
but the autopsy from the spanish coroner
came out and said it was a suicide yeah
interesting story about his wife a
prostitute in miami
yeah yeah i met her there yeah and like
apparently the sweetest lady
better there wifed it up saved her
that's it good for her son that's the
story like i need that
that's pretty woman yeah that is
literally a pretty woman this guy was
living that life
man scooped up a pro in miami he said
you're mine
let's travel the world not pay taxes you
think that richard gere's character was
paying all his taxes and pretty well
rich
probably hiding that corporate money no
chance not paying not a single penny
warren buffett stop
working around the law like a cup
richard what's his name mac if he said i
don't believe in the law [ __ ] the law
openly
out everybody else bezos paying zero
taxes legally
this guy said [ __ ] that i'm gonna do it
because i don't believe in this thing
i'm gonna do it the illegal way
i got a wife that [ __ ] you know
so yeah we'd have to see i'm curious you
know like what the autopsy is and on top
of that like i have to see like motive
like why like what dirt does he have and
then they said he has a dead man switch
and that didn't come out
so he says don't if someone kills me i
have a dead man switch if the devin
switch is a lie
yeah then is everything else surrounding
how you say you guys
think he wants some hoopla bro like i
think man loves hoopla dawg
and if you know you're gonna kill
yourself you might as well create some
hoopla you got a history of hoopla i
will say
this is someone that i don't think seems
like they're mentally altogether
exactly i don't know if you necessarily
did it like cognizant of like oh i'm
going to stir
up like i'll kill myself i'm out but
like i'm going to create this whole [ __ ]
storm
i think he's getting extra being like oh
they're really going to do something
awful to me
like he's just like this parent always
schizophrenic that's like oh this
they're gonna do some crazy [ __ ] i'm
gonna be in guantanamo like blah blah
blah
i'm gonna take myself out before yeah
and then they'll never believe that i
actually took myself
out yeah like i wonder if you almost had
it as like like a cyanide pill kind of
thing
that like if [ __ ] gets bad yeah i can
just bite down on this and then
take myself out but no one's going to
think i took myself up you know what i
mean
ah yeah by creating this narrative
beforehand yeah he always has an out
yes and he basically just creates the
narrative because he's an egomaniac
i'm so important that the government
would have to take me out like you're
not that important
like that's another thing to all these
people who think you're so important
that the deep state is taking you out
it's like we don't care right
i think he thinks it though he he truly
believes it and all these people truly
believe it and that's their psychosis
but like
i guess one thing that like the covet
taught me the pandemic taught me like
like we don't care like that bread and
circus [ __ ] is true
yeah like you give people twelve hundred
dollars they don't care about episteme
no more
yeah you know what i mean you give them
hundred dollars they can buy themselves
a new dishwasher and [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] if it's ufos out
there netflix tracking
yo a new series is coming out game of
thrones is coming back what
yeah we don't care about ufos bro all we
need is enough distraction to not give a
[ __ ] about you
and the only way the government [ __ ] up
is that they don't give us enough
distraction yep
if there's not enough discretion we
gonna find it and when we start looking
you can look into some dark areas yeah
right there's some bad things out there
and that's just prote that is our like
pretend distraction yeah we're gonna out
the government no we're not
we're not going anywhere just to
distract us yes we just want that's the
circus
so give a circus bro give us some ufos
give us some drama with billionaires
every once in a while
sacrifice uh what's his face bill gates
to the game
like if you got to sacrifice bill gates
to keep [ __ ] moving beautiful
you know what i mean sacrifice him would
not be sacrificed i don't mean kill him
but like
dig up all this drama make him a bad guy
make him look bad right
oh yeah and then we gonna we're gonna
kill him publicly or give us some [ __ ]
to talk about we'll feel absolutely
amazing as we trash this billionaire
what an evil piece of [ __ ] and then
warren buffett's next
matter of fact if i'm warrick buffett
i'd i'd i'd uh
i offered myself you know back in the
day in tribal times when you were the
old person you were burdened on a tribe
remember you just like all right i'm
gonna go out to the woods and i'll just
stay there because i don't want to be a
burden on you guys carrying me around
and [ __ ] like that
that's what buffer should do i'm 90 i
had a great life my time
say i'm a pedophile saying whatever the
[ __ ] you want me to say give the people
the circus they need to keep this [ __ ]
moving
yep cause that's all we need is some
distraction
circus it's all the circus it's the
circus we
ringling brothers out here yeah yeah and
if [ __ ] cable tv was doing their job
we wouldn't need all the government to
step in
i'm saying bro that's why trump was so
mad at snl he's like come on
dude they're killing me out here doing
your job
make people laugh so i don't have to oh
all right anything we should touch on
before we got it